hello everyone and welcome to round two
of the FTX crypto cup it is a world
champion Magnus Carlson versus Hans
moken Iman and it is uh quite a brutal
game to witness one of the players took
uh well I'm just gonna call it serious
beating and uh it's uh it's a very
enjoyable game as Han smoke and Iman uh
plays a line that Magnus is known to
play himself quite a lot in the Sicilian
Defense so let's dive straight into it
yeah and see what happens here and you
might think okay this is a completely
new territory just by you know after a
couple of new moves after a couple of uh
first moves have been played uh but it
is actually there's actually quite a lot
of theory involved in this so let's uh
check it out Magnus has the white pieces
and he opens with E4 we have C5 by
Neiman Knight to F3 Knight to C6 and
Bishop to B5 going for the Nish medino
rossolimo G6 and now Magnus Castle we
have Bishop to G7 Rook to E1 and now
Knight to F6 putting pressure on for
Pawn Magnus advances at the E5 we have
Knight to D5 preparing Knight to C7 to
harass the light Square Bush appear
Knight to C3 and Knight the C7 so like I
said all has been played before nothing
new here Bishop captures the characters
and now Knight to E4 this is uh all
known Theory and considered the best uh
B6 by Neiman and now Knight to F6 check
by Magnus even this has been played
quite a few times uh and you do not want
to accept this play captures then Pawn
captures opens up a discovery with the
Rogue now the bishop hangs and it's just
a silly position to play Just captures
captures without the dark Square bishop
and with white having the dark Square
Bishop look at all these dark Square
weaknesses here around the black king it
should be a fairly clean game for white
so after Knight F6 check King to faded
this is how this is played Knight back
to E4 and now Bishop to G4 so playing it
uh like a normal position only with the
King and f8 but later on you're gonna
play H6 like King G8 King H7 bringing
the Rook into the game and so on we have
Pawn to D3 and now comes Knight to E6
now uh there is a game where Bishop
captures an E5 was played Daniel dubov
played it against Ralph mavadov and lost
the game in the Euro Team Championship
in 2017 uh and um as Magnus is very good
friends with dubov and they both played
the Slime I imagine Magnus is familiar
with this uh so instead we have Knight
to the E6 by Neiman uh kind of
surprising Magnus but uh not really as
this is still all explore territory
Knight eat the G5 uh now
um just having a beautiful piece here
Knight captures Bishop captures and now
Queen to D5 a beautiful centralizing
move by Neiman uh putting pressure on
the Knight here maybe you can to play
Bishop captures and F3 mess up
white spawn structure and then the E5
Pawn might become weak in the future but
Magnum just plays Rook D4 cuts off uh
the Queen's uh attack towards the Knight
and is now threatening to pick up the
bishop and now you have to make a choice
do you play the bishop captures on F3 or
do you play Bishop to F5 and force
magnus's Rook to move back now Bishop
captures and F3 is very interesting and
there is
um a a game that reached this exact same
position it was a game grendelius versus
nihal sarin that grandel is won very
nicely Bishop captures an F3 proved to
be a bit too hard to play for black you
do win a pawn here uh for example Queen
captures and F3 and now if Bishop
captures an E5 yes you've grabbed the
pawn but now and also you are
threatening Bishop captures on H2 and
you want to win the bishop and G5 but
after Queen E3 guarding the bishop
putting more pressure on E7 preparing
Rook 8 to E1 it is very hard to
correctly play this with black I can
show you how you can do it Bishop
captures on B2 see C4 we chase away the
queen queen to F5 and now Bishop to H6
with check you're gonna block with the
bishop and now Rook to E1 so if Bishop
captures Queen captures everything is
perfectly fine you are putting pressure
on this spawn here and it is incredibly
difficult to actually uh pull off
playing this with black so instead niman
goes Bishop to F5 and now Magnus plays
Pawn to C4 and I just want to check
something uh I I don't want to trick you
guys yeah there is actually one game
where C4 was played uh attacking the
queen but in that game Queen to D7 was
played here we have
uh here instead of Queen 37 we have
Queen to E6 and it is now as of move 16
that we have a completely new game so uh
Neiman is the one that chooses new
territory uh and now magnus's Rook is
still hanging so Rook E3 and now Pawn to
H6 and this will now uh prove to be
quite a handful uh to handle for Magnus
Bishop to F4 we have G5 chasing away the
bishop Bishop to G3 and now Rook to d8
with the idea of bringing the other Rook
into the game uh with the most King Jade
King H7 and then this Rook will come
into play and by playing C4 it is
something that uh Lego Peter meant when
he said pawns can go backwards it's a
very old thing in chess but you have to
be very careful when you push the pawn
forward as it can never go backwards and
now this is a weakness for the rest of
the game of course Neiman will hone in
on it and the magnets will of course
have to do whatever he can to defend it
so here upon the H3 stopping G4 but now
King to G8 with Ponte A3 preparing B4
King to H7 with B4 by Magnus and Rook to
D7 now preparing to double up on the D
file and really put pressure on this D3
Pawn you can even put more pressure with
Queen to G6 so uh how will Magnus defend
this he can he has two Rooks he has a
queen and the Knight the Knight will
come to E1 to defend the pawn but it
will be a very very passive position so
here B captures on C5 we have V captures
and queen to B3 now now The Rook can
come to D1 so everyone defends the D3
pawn and Rook H to d8 adding another
attacker Rook to D1 Magnus adds another
Defender and queen to G6 Neiman adds
another attacker to the D3 Pawn Knights
the E1 Magnus adds a Defender and down
and luckily for Magnus there's no way to
actually add another attacker all of
your pieces are attacking it and you
have a dark Square Bishop this is a
light square square uh so of course the
dark Square Bishop cannot attack it H5
now preparing to go after the bishop or
even a bus open the position with G4 and
now Magnus plays the very tricky Knight
to F3 saying that okay I've removed one
of the Defenders of the D3 Pawn but if
you capture my Pawn I can play Knight
captures on G5 with check and now if you
capture with the queen you no longer
defend your Bishop so I can start
capturing on D3 Sony man uh continues uh
pushing forward H4 attacking Carlson's
bishop and not Magnus plays Bishop to H2
and this is where things start to get
seriously wrong for Magnus instead of
Bishop to H2 there was the very tricky
E6 move that you could throw in because
okay The Rook is hanging on these seven
and once this bishop is captured you can
play the active Bishop to E5 more so it
will be a little bit better but still
not easy to play for Magnus but after
Bishop to H2 now Neiman plays E6 and now
there is no more E6 for Magnus and this
bishop is just a very very silly piece
so Queen to C3 and now Bishop to f8 uh
you have to make room for The Rook
something like Bishop to E7 and then
maybe the Rooks will go to the G file if
you push G4 open up the position to
start attacking so it might be very
useful Knight's the E1 by Magnus and now
Pawn to G4 we have H captors Bishop
captures and now Pawn to F3 uh creating
new weaknesses in front of the white
king but um you you really have no
options here your Rook was hanging and
you don't really want to move it if you
play something like Rook D2 then Bishop
H6 and then you just resign so here
Bishop to F5 uh Bishop to F5 is a nice
move uh Bishop to H6 might be an even
better one it's a free Tempo The Rook
here is hanging and once The Rook moves
then you call Bishop to F5 so but maybe
any man just felt that his position was
so overwhelming that maybe bishop to H6
wasn't needed so so you just saw Bishop
to F5 and he played it without uh you
know being even interested in in playing
it even better because what's you know
if you have something really good it
might be pointless to go for better if
it's a rapid game so here Pawn to F4 now
not Magnus really without any active
most play and Bishop to H6 now attack a
putting pressure on the pawn here we
have Queen the A5 by Magnus now going
after the C5 Pawn but just Queen G4
saying you can have your Pawn I'm
attacking your Rook on D1 and here
Magnus played Rook to F3 just uh
blocking the The Queen's attack towards
the rook and there are a couple of nice
moves Neiman can play here and uh
probably most of them are winning
but there is one that is absolutely
crushing so feel free to pause the video
here and try to win this game for Neiman
uh while I give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting either
Rook to B8 or or Rook to G8 those are
all very very impressive moves but the
move Neiman played and that is the
absolute most precise way to play is
Bishop Bishop to E4 and now there just
isn't a move for Magnus uh you can't
capture the bishop because the Rook on
D1 just hangs you can't move this Rook
because then we pick up this Rook so
what can you play here Magnus played
Queen captures in C5 he has to give up
some material uh and now uh that's
pretty much it the bishop captures
Knight captures on F3 now even H3
threatening Checkmate so Queen to F2
Magnus defense but now Rook captures and
D3 we have Rook captures Rook captures
and now Knight to E1 attacking The Rook
also blocking the back rank from any
Rook to D1 checks so Rook captures an A3
and now Queen to B2 Magnus puts pressure
on The Rook but now Rook back to E3 just
attacks the Knight King F2 uh this is uh
the the you know the the last hope that
something good might happen for Magnus
but here just Bishop captures an F4 and
he was in this position on move 42 that
Magnus Carlsen resigned the game and the
first uh game goes to Han smoke and
Neiman uh we'll see if Magnus will be
able to bounce back but this was an
incredibly impressive win with the black
pieces against world champion Magnus
Carlsen in a line that he is all too
familiar with and here you resign uh you
you really don't have them whatever you
play I mean uh Queen captures on G2 if
the Knight moves Queen captures and G2
just wins uh if you don't uh I mean what
what do you play here if you play
something like Pawn captures G captures
on H3 you just get to checkmated it's uh
nothing fun to look at just Queen H4
check King to F1 and now you're gonna
start capturing Queen captures on F1
King to G2 rookie to check also wins the
White Queen so that's pretty much
pointless and if you try something like
Queen to C2 jerk first try and start
some trouble after King to G7 there are
no more useful checks and now it's
pretty much the same thing with G
captures on H3 pretty much runs into the
same thing Queen H4 checking G1 Queen
captures here with check King G2 and now
even captures on H2 threatening this a
queen G1 Checkmate and if you capture it
we don't even have to win the White
Queen we can just deliver a nice
Checkmate like this queen G3 trick King
H1 and Rook D1 uh will be Checkmate so
brilliant brilliant play by Niemann uh
taking down Magnus in this beautiful
line of the Sicilian Defense of the of
the earth against the rosalimo basically
so we'll see if Magnus repeats this in
game three uh but uh you know so far he
it didn't seem like he had absolutely uh
anything uh under control even having
the white pieces in this game uh so yeah
that's the game I hope you guys enjoyed
once again really awesome stuff by
Neiman uh we'll see what happens in the
other games I would like to thank Peter
Rodriguez Alex vasilio Francis air Ricky
emini and excellent subscriber for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
FDX crypto cup until it finishes uh most
likely uh so thank you all I will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day